[Music]
Nicole Kidman is that you it's very
unusual the oscar-winning actress is
barely recognizable onset of her
upcoming film destroyer Kidman underwent
a major makeover for her new role in the
crime drama as police detective Erin
Bell the actress swapped out her
gorgeous hair for a short brunette wig
fake tan and loose-fitting clothes I had
a number of experiences over the years
and this is completely new this isn't
the first time 50 year old Nicole has
altered her look for a role remember
Kidman transforming into a homely
looking novelist in 2002 the hours she
has the knife she's eating oh book she's
writing anyone that has curly hair
that's young keep your curly head then
the actress went back to her curly
haired roots for her role in top of the
late China girl from her fake gap to the
prosthetic bulge added to the top of her
nose
Kidman went all out but it's her
performance in 2016 lion where she truly
transformed and earned her fourth Oscar
nomination playing the real-life subir
Lee when tequila rolls come along with
particular times and they align directly
with your
personal feelings and then it's sort of
like you just give over choice did you
recognize Kidman in her latest movie
makeover and let me know which on-screen
transformation you think is her most
shocking in the comments below
[Music]
you